je pense et je la firme dire que
monsieur castaner l'a fait
qu'aujourd'hui le problème des sans abri
c'est qu'ils refusent des logements pour
derrière faire une circulaire qui remet
en cause un principe sacré de la
république monsieur collomb donc qui est
celui de l'accueil inconditionnel de
celui qui est le plus miséreux et qui a
besoin d'un toit ça nous n'allons plus
le faire où nous ne le ferions plus si
cette circulaire était appliquée au
point que ceux qui s'occupent des
pauvres dans ce pays dix-sept
associations caritatives de d'emmaüs au
secours catholique à la fondation abbé
pierre qui sont quand même pas des
organisations habitué aux coups d'éclat
gauchistes objectivement elles font leur
boulot sur le terrain font un recours
devant le conseil d'état contre cette
circulaire parce qu'elle est indigne
d'un grand pays civilisé donc avant de
faire des grands discours sur la
mondialisation et les
laissés-pour-compte du monde
arrêtons arrêtez monsieur macron arrêtez
monsieur mabut ouvriers de piétiner les
droits avaient laissés pour compte
ici en france quelle que soit leur
origine qu'ils soient français ou
étrangers arrêtés de piétiner leurs
droits et en piétinant leurs droits leur
dignité
à commencer par respecter la dignité des
personnes âgées chez nous fait
mettez sur la table j'y suis prêt moi
puisque à ce qu'on les partis politiques
les associations les syndicats se penche
sur l'avenir de notre modèle de prise en
charge du grand âge travail ou d'enfants
mais on verra alors sur les arguments
par benoît hamon est ce que je veux dire
il avait été laissé pour mort la monnaie
de singe c'est toujours par les laisser
moment par exemple pour être clair
est-ce que vous estimez que la france
doit accueillir comme elle le fait et
comme elle proclame qu'elle continuera à
le faire bien sûr les demandeurs d'asile
qui sont victimes dans leurs crédits de
persécution et faut-il également
accueillir tous les réfugiés économiques
et bouna mais c'est ça la question mais
non nous s'est passé avec ses magazines
j'en vienne louis met d'accord mais
objectivement il ya des gens qui
arrivent pas si nombreux que ça et qui
viennent ou parce qu'ils sont dans la
misère chez eux ou parce qu'il fut le
rejoignait faut pas faire de différence
ou non mais attendez ici évidemment que
l'asile
c'est je suis pour moi renforcer la
ville ou parce qu'ils fuient les
conflits
aujourd'hui la france rennes pour
l'asile dissuade certaines personnes qui
veulent demander l'asile de le faire en
imposant des délais qui nous
correspondent pas à la loi je vous
pourrez vous prendre certains
départements dans lesquels je me suis
rendu ou pour un premier rendez vous là
où la loi impose que ce premier rendez
vous soit au moins fixé dans un délai de
trois à onze jours et il faut plusieurs
mais gérard collomb veut réduire le
délai à simon mais pour l'instant
pour que votre dossier sur l'instru
encore faut-il pouvoir être enregistrés
et bien pour pouvoir être enregistrés
nous jouions c'est normal c'est
montbazens et conditionne les gens de se
faire enregistrer
donc c'est ça la réalité qu'est ce qui
fait qu'aujourd'hui des grandes voix de
partout au delà des responsables
politiques dont on pense qu'ils sont
suspects de s'en prendre à emmanuel
macron parce que c'est emmanuel macron
prothèses de cette politique là c'est
qu'elle est indigne de la république et
de la rendre le fait-il alors qu'alex en
glisse à la gestion du monde mais moi
j'ai pas sérieuse aux dires de gérard
collomb rien pour les associations pense
pas il a répondu ondéron là dessus
pourquoi est ce qu'ils font ça parce que
l'opinion public nous suit oui au niveau
bien mais je veux nommer benzéma pn
connaît les meilleurs de rona entend
sont en sont mais non l'allemagne arrêté
mais l'allemagne mais elle a fait
d'abord un million de réfugiés monsieur
pécresse vous êtes fan donc je veux bien
mais on a pris nos noms mais on a appris
ça ce que dizaines de milliers ça s'est
il n'en a cure
ils ont accueilli voulait mal m'en a
mené sur ce terrain-là plaignant est ce
qu'un autant d'allemands mais je pense
encore j'aimerais apprendre comment
fonctionne allemagne pour ne pas
mépriser en allemagne on a le choix des
tice dès le premier jour en allemagne et
une prise en charge psychologique parce
que c'est personne n'a sont souvent en
août à la mairie laisse des mois de
l'exil et des traversées sont très
atteints sur le plan purement jour d'hui
oui mais ce que je veux dire c'est
qu'ils ont eu à 1 ils ont fait un effort
considérable nous ferons ferait le quart
de cela que ça provoquerait au sommet
des manuels d'un cran durant à la
réponse rendue à la générosité dans gala
merkel vous souvenez il l'avait dit
alors aujourd'hui vous êtes
générosité de mme merkel pour oublier
lui-même d'être généreux